as if the coronavirus is not enough to
worry about hurricane season is
approaching and that will put an
incredible strain on already stressed
federal emergency managers correspondent
Jillian Turner shows us how tonight as
coronavirus continues claiming an
average of 2,000 American lives per day
crisis response teams are now bracing
for another added threat team is already
responding to tornadoes and earthquakes
that have occurred this year as you
mentioned June 1st is hurricane season
they have to be prepared at the same
time they're responding to coated the
combination creates a threat landscape
the homeland security chief calls
unprecedented that's what FEMA is doing
now is coordinating response at 50
states territories all hitting at the
same time and they haven't done that in
their 41-year history before now
FEMA's administrator says it also
creates a logistics puzzle part of the
the mission was to accelerate the
movement of PPE from around the world so
where we could find it is get at the
United States over the past month DHS
built a new crisis Coordination Response
Center it's called the surge where a
hundred and fifty officials will oversee
hurricane surfed rescue and evacuation
operations all while keeping Americans
safe from contracting coronavirus how do
you shelter individuals from a natural
disaster in a kovat environment well you
can't you got to have to do things a
little differently the surge is meant to
support the hundreds of crisis response
cells already operating at FEMA
headquarters
it'll only Philip is needed so they hope
it never has to you guys are planning
for all kinds of scenarios what's the
worst-case scenario you're anticipating
a worst-case scenario would be a very
hectic hurricane season that we would
see multiple hurricanes hitting at the
same time or very similar or close by
that theme was having to respond to at
the same time as Kovan that's not to say
they can't do it they absolutely can do
it 15 Americans died in hurricanes last
season and so far over 76,000 Americans
have died in the Cova 19 pandemic Brett
Jillian thank you